hello everyone hi my name is michael
and uh
um
i'm sorry i can't be here you know i
really want to be a business meeting
person but um it's not meant to be
anyway so um
the the title of my talk is running
javascript paisa and ruby in web
assembly so essentially running
scripting language in web assembly right
you know so
since we had a technical audience so i
would just cut to the chats right you
know a heart started you know web
was originally designed not to be a
scripting language runtime right you
know it's uh because we were unsatisfied
with javascript performance we want to
run cc plus plus code rust code and the
compiled language code you know those um
close native performance right you know
um those applications alongside um
javascript you know so that javascript
applications can take advantage of that
so it's meant as a supplement to
javascript so as such inside the browser
the web assembly runtime route side by
side of this javascript right you know
so you have a you have a javascript
runtime and web assembly runtime there
is a bridge between them and if you are
writing
rust applications and compared to
webassembly you would have something
called the watson by j and if you are
running
compiling c applications
it would be something else
so essentially there would be a web
assembly runtime with a bridge that goes
to javascript the javascript runtime
acts as a host for the webinar meaning
the web assembly runtime just to run the
computation but uh the the data the
the networking data file system and all
that were provided by the javascript
runtime and the made available to the
web assembly application through the
bridge right you know so that's
the original design you know so our
original design web assembly really is
to run compiler applications not to run
a
java screen language application like
javascript
you know so
what has changed so
how it's going you know why are we
talking about web assembly running you
know javascript running inside website
now well before we get to why you know
let's see you know how it starts you
know that's because again we are
technical audience here right you know
so strictly speaking
it can be done right you know because as
um we just talked about whether somebody
runs
applications compiled from c superspace
and rust
and then you know um although in the
browser is typically around side by side
with javascript right but
you know what is written in c supplies
plus rust practical practically
everything right including
all the javascript a lot of those
javascript runtimes interpreters python
runtime interpreters ruby around having
interpreters those are all written in cc
plus plus or rust
so they can be compiled into webassembly
once you compile those into webassembly
you would have a webassembly application
that then you can feed the javascript
source code python source code or ruby
source code to run them inside
webassembly so to run web to run
javascript inside webassembly you do
a nested architecture you know so you
have a web assembly wrong time on the
outer shell and it has a
compiled
javascript runtime or python runtime
whatever what have you inside it and as
a web assembly application and then you
have um you know different api modules
to provide access you know like
networking or you know we're going to
talk about those later but then the
scripting language application itself is
feed
into the web assembly application and
get executed there right you know so
that's the overall architecture so we
know it can be done
and a lot of the content in this talk is
um you know we have that on our website
so the example applications and all that
so
um you know so if you missed anything
you you know don't worry that's i mean
all the source codes available
and so you know we know it can be done
but why you know that's uh why do you
need
to run
um screaming language applications such
as javascript python ruby side web
assembly so
the reason really is because web
assembly is growing
in popularity you know people are you
know because although it's start from
the use case where the native compiled
native applications run inside this
browser is now on the server side on the
edge on mobile devices on other places
and people want to
um
you know
the the traditional c-supplies plus
developers or rust developers are using
web assembly but new developers also
want to use webassembly and a lot of
those new developers want to use
javascript and python you know so
there's has been increasing need i think
in the last um maybe two years that's uh
we have heard a lot from our customers
from our community you know um how you
know how they want to use javascript and
python and ruby to a lesser extent in
web assembly because simply because
those are very popular languages a lot
of people know that a lot of people
knows you know um to write especially to
write simple embedded functions that's
uh that's that that are ideally suited
for webassembly
so next let let's look at some use cases
of web assembly to understand why the
scripting languages are so important
so here are some use cases you know we
we touched on them casually just you
know
just now
so the first of course you know um is
what web assembly has been
been very successful is to
extend existing applications with user
defined functions you know so um you
have applications that written in um any
number of languages you know us to see
java you know whatever and then you want
to turn your software into a platform
into a pass right you know by allowing
your users or other people to customize
it
by adding their own functions to your
software right you know essentially
turning your um you know this is what we
call application serverless right you
know that's uh you know adding some
for the user to add serverless functions
or user defined functions into your
application and that customize it to do
the jobs that they want right you know
so
um
in that case the user um the application
itself may be written in say rust or go
you know whatever but um
but the
extension functions or the serverless
functions is oftentimes written in the
in a language that is local so you know
javascript and python
are i would say you know a fairly
popular languages that people want to
use for this particular use case right
and then there's um called h-cloud use
cases i mean you know that's uh you know
um
for instance the the the compute node on
cdn networks or um you know five five gm
ecs you know those are data centers um
on the edge that outside of the cloud
big cloud data centers that are closer
to the to the end users and you know so
there are a number of
application use cases there so for
instance there's uh isomorphic rendering
you know so meaning the server-side
rendering of react or server-side
rendering of popular javascript
frameworks you know today you know those
are um those are rendered inside say
node.js or the node.js or dnode running
inside docker right you know all inside
of vm and is our way to run those
javascripts in a lightweight environment
such as web assembly and there's ai
inference right you know so you have um
you know
pictures or other data captured by edge
devices and it's we are economical to
send it all all the way back to the to
the cloud data center to process them
and we can process them right on the
edge in edge cloud and um you know and
have the results stored there or have
you know generate actions from there and
you know things like that
and then there's age devices there's h
devices use cases you know webassembly
because website is a lightweight runtime
so it can run on mobile devices as a
cross-platform runtime
essentially replacing the jvm in a lot
of cases so you can uh you can embed a
web assembly around time inside a mobile
application like uh like
amazon has done with amazon prime video
you know that so they have a
those a video player they have um needs
to run um you know c based uh you know
applications and in order to
um
simplify the the work to ports uh the
to run the sea based applications across
um you know according to their blog over
8 000 different devices types you know
all kinds of android devices and ios and
you know things like that and so they
need uh in the middle layer that's that
provide cross-platform compatibility and
web assembly the uh with ability to
um you know web assembly would be you
know one looks ideal you um you know
runtimes for this purpose right so but
yeah but in this case whether somebody
not should not only be able to run say c
or us
compile native code but should also be
able to run um say you know javascript
and python things like that
and then um
last you know there's uh um you know um
there's
um
a very big set of use cases that we have
seen uh we're probably seeing today from
from this um
from the cognitive wasn't there is that
um you know
a very interesting use case of web
assembly is to use it as a standalone
container you know directly managed by
kubernetes right you know so you could
have
you could have a service mesh that has
you know docker-based or linux-based
services and but also have web
summary-based services and the in and in
this case you know there's uh um
you know for a lot of computing tasks we
especially embedded computing tasks you
know dark
linux containers could be too
heavyweight
and i'm so
you know we we want to write the service
we want to write for microservices in
web assembly and uh
and in this case you know java
javascript and the python both provide
very um you know compelling um you know
um
service frameworks for you know for
running those microservices so those are
so those are the reasons why you know
the use cases
why do you want the wrong javascript or
python inside webassembly
so
um for today's talk you know we're gonna
spend perhaps
um you know um most of the time talk
about javascript you know because that's
like we said this is one this is this is
the most important use case and we're
going to talk about python and ruby at
the end of this talk
so the way to run javascript inside
webassembly like i've just said is to
take a c c plus space to javascript um
interpreter or javascript runtime engine
and compile it into webassembly around
you can do everything bytecode and run
as a web assembly application right you
know so um this is work that's that
people have done you know that's we have
done this as well but um you know um the
community
you know um you know have have been
supported one of the you know most
lightweight and quickest um you know
javascript um interpreter called quickjs
um into web assembly so as you can see
the example here it's about leveraging
the web assembly was it standard meaning
that you know to have
this
quick js runtime running inside the
weber summary runtime in this particular
case it was managed type it would have
access to the operating system it would
access to the um to the command line
argument for instance and it will have
access to the local directory so it will
be able to read files and read from the
command line you know and you know
basically around a very standard um
javascript so it can essentially you can
put any
javascript content here and be able to
run it right you know so that's
um you know that's
the basic stuff you know that's not to
have um to have a quick js runtime
compiling webassembly to run any pure
javascript content
and with this with this quick yes
um it's um you know
it's very easy to have you know uh es6
module you know so meaning that's um now
we can um you know with
um
with the quickjs runtime inside the web
assembly you know inside say was match
it can have access to the operating
system so it can read multiple js files
right you know so you can now have um
you know es6 syntax to um you know to
export and import functions across
different files you know so here is
example you know so at the top panel you
have a you have an exported function
called hello and then you have uh on the
top panel on the on the other side you
have a synchronously exported function
and also
a variable a string right and then you
know uh in the middle panel you have the
um you know the the the javascript
application that imports
the
um you know the es6 modules because the
imports
was imported from the file system so
it's a it could be a synchronous
operation it could also be a
a a synchronous operation right you know
so it depends on the the
the syntax flavor that you want to use
you could do it asynchronously or
synchronously and so both are fine and
we want to demonstrate both use cases
and then you know using the quickjs
runtime you can you can load this and
run inside webassembly and you can see
the results here you know that's uh you
know
it would be able to execute it would be
able to import those functions from
those modules and execute them right you
know so that's a very simple example of
you know how to run uh yes six modules
inside the web
inside web assembly
and uh um
the um so es6 module is uh it's a it's a
relatively new standard for javascript
um
for a lot of older javascripts um you
know especially the ones that in the in
the node.js ecosystem um we are still
using the the common js module cjs
module you know to um there's lots of
javascript libraries are written in that
way so in order to use cjs we have uh we
use another tool called um
uh called raw app so you know that's
essentially you know there's uh um
you use rob.js
to um to package a javascript
application that imports those npm
modules into a single file you know
that's essentially it's it takes down
also it's it's pulls down all those um
module files from from npm repository
and then combining them into a big file
and then you know you can use website
you can use
the quickjs environment inside web or
something to run the entire file right
you know so that's um you know so we
also have a demonstration here you know
that's basically it takes uh um
you know
the um digital signature module and then
computes md5 and it's also that's what
you know takes one of the mass libraries
and computes that so you know so those
are so you know uh through rawa.js we
can also support um you know uh
common.js modules and a large part of
the
npm ecosystem a lot of npm modules can
be supported this way
but if that's you know if we just
support es6 and
and cgs they'll be you know it'll be
interesting but um perhaps not yet
compelling and what i find most
compelling that adds new features to um
you know to running javascript inside
web assignments really to um is to allow
um
rust-based implementations and
webassembly and javascript to interact
with each other meaning that you know
you could have you could write a
function in rust and then expose this
function as a javascript api so as a so
as a javascript developer they would not
need to know the rust implementation
behind it that we just need to call the
api so so um a lot of this api is
provided by um by quickjs itself and our
roster wrap is around quickjs right you
know so um on the left side you can see
there's a there's a there's a rust
function that is um
you know designed to interact with
javascript so it has
constructs like the js function and js
value and even things like that and then
on
on the right side is that we
we
when we compile the
the quick js runtime we now have hooks
to import this function this function is
a struct called flow fn right and give
it name you know in the context given
name called hi so
so then we run a javascript
um
you know
in the javascript we can simply refer
this function as high right you know so
the the the javascript code is um um you
know is is on the right panel it's code
equals to high one two three right you
know that's uh so meaning in javascript
we just call hi 123 and the javascript
interpreter sees the symbol knows it's a
building function that it can find its
implementation in rust so it goes to ros
to find this implementation and execute
this function and then give you the
results right you know so the um you
know on the right you can also see the
the uh
the result from this so you know um oh
why do we do that the way the the reason
to do that is that you know um so for
the
for a lot of tasks that pure javascript
is kind of slow or it's difficult to do
you know so the ability to have the
ability to use um to write
those tasks in rust and then have the
whole thing compiled into webassembly
allows us to mix the ease of use of
javascript and the high performance of
rust right you know that's really taking
advantage of
webassembly's capability to run both
right you know to be able to run
you know rust compiled applications and
also javascript applications as
interpreter right you know so i think
this is one of the um
you know
compelling cases of why you want you
want to run javascript inside
webassembly because you could
potentially run faster and safer right
so
with that in mind you know so um we um
you know i want to introduce you to some
some of the um
you know rust apis that we have already
built with our um you know because i
work at
united internet at uh at wasm edge you
know so at one mesh we have um some rust
extensions sdk extensions web assembly
you know that's uh so we build some of
the functionalities um as javascript
apis using the approach that i've just
mentioned right you know so um for
instance here that's uh you know as we
know um a networking socket has been a
long amazing feature from wazi but at
watson edge we added our own
non-blocking asynchronous networking
you know
socket support right and we have a rust
sdk for that so in our quick gs
implementation we have in our quick js
setup we have
we have a rust module that implements uh
http module inside javascript so meaning
that's when running quickjs inside was
an edge you could write javascript
that's uh that does http request and
does http and become http server as well
as uh because http server could be
asynchronous meaning that it's not
blocking right you know it can handle um
multiple concurrent um you know
connections at the same time from the
same port
you know using the same thread right you
know so so there's uh so by
incorporating a roster-based io library
that was mesh has provided for
for each web assembly implementation we
would be able to support you know
networking based java javascript
applications invoice match just using
the uh
the
the techniques
i've just mentioned right
that's along the same line of sort you
can we can do the fetch api right you
know uh we can do http because when we
can do the simple http request
and the http server so we can do the
fetch um you know that's uh we're going
to talk about the significance of this
api
in a couple of slides and you can also
do the um you know
one of the interesting features of
watson edge is it provides uh extension
for tensorflow so it also have was a
wasting an extension for open miner you
know meaning that's um you know um
you can use rust to write
uh ai inference applications and have
them compiled into webassembly and runs
inside was image you would know
to use the gpu or to use other
you know
hardware or software components
available on the device to do the ai
inference and because this is a rust api
for that extension we can also
incorporate that into javascript api
using the technique we have just
mentioned right so here is a is an
example of javascript application that
you can run inside inside was managed to
take advantage of the um the
tensorflow extension
so
now we have talked about you know that's
uh we have we have networking we can
have you know those um those those
native functions in inside the web
assembly so one of the uh when we
combine those together one of the more
interesting things that we can do on
watson edge is really to do
server side rendering for
um
for for react applications so in
react-18 there's a there's a
way to do server-side running called
streams ssr and the way it works is to
fetch the data from the
from other servers first build the model
and render html and then send html
across the wire to the to the browser to
do um and then be rendered as uh as a ui
in the browser right you know so
this whole generating the html dom
components and the rendered content into
it
you know can all be done on the on the
edge server you know um
inside the web somebody long time now so
in the past you know you have to have
node.js or dno and then have them
wrapped inside a docker container to do
that you know now we have you know and
now we have a web of somebody wrong time
that is that is much much faster that is
much much smaller and almost as fast
right
so there's a there's a
uh example website and tutorials that
you can you can try on your own you know
so you can take a react 18 application
and make little changes to um how the
ssr server is wrong because you are not
no longer using node.js you are using um
you know um the non-blocking socket
involves a mesh so there's um
there's a tiny bit of code changes there
and once you do that you know you will
be able to you would be able to launch
it and run it on the
you know on your edge server
so
you know now you know one of the common
questions i get is uh you know when
you're choosing quickjs you know how
does that compare with v8 you know
that's because we ate
behind node.js and dino as the
high-performance javascript engine can
be as fast as
v8 lan says no quickjs is the
interpreter it's uh it doesn't have git
so it's much slower than v8 however as
we said you know one of the things is
that a lot of those uh bottlenecks like
you know a huge time consuming um you
know tasks like generating strings you
know ai inference and you know seeing a
network concurrent networking and all
that stuff it can be done in rust you
know so you don't have to do them in in
javascript in that case you know the
overall performance of application may
not necessarily be much slower you know
just of course the true benefit of using
quickjs and webassembly is that it's
much much smaller so v8 is like 40
megabytes in memory but uh quickjs is
like less than one megabyte so uh even
adding web assembly it's still much
smaller than say you know
a v8 inside docker right you know and
the um
quickjs in web assembly is also safer
because um um webassembly runtime itself
is a security sandbox and uh it has much
smaller attack surface for uh you know
for security issues and it's also more
manageable you know because whether
somebody runtime itself is uh is oci
components can be managed by kubernetes
and the same uh you know in order for v8
to do that you have to wrap it around in
this container which make it much much
bigger and heavier right
you know so of course there's other
approaches to run javascript inside
inside the web assembly you know one of
the leading
alternative is spidermonkey you know
that's uh the javascript engine the
javascript engine that's used in firefox
so there's articles um and and also code
on how to do that and then there's uh
shopify has a project called javi and
it's also a set of rust wrappers and
tools around quickjs that shopify has
developed
you know that's uh um
that allows um you know um a pretty much
it's it's a similar approach that
than the one that that i have just uh
that i've just
that i've just described so check it out
so the other way to do that is really to
um incorporate v8 into webassembly using
v8 as a host function you know meaning
that you pass javascript evaluation
directly into v8 but that's something
you know that's something that we are
experimenting with and you know if you
are interested you know we we could talk
more after this talk
yeah so you know that's the same thing
about web assembly now we have a couple
minutes left so we'll talk a little bit
about python and uh um and uh and ruby
as well so for python you know
so for
javascript we took a javascript
interpreter and compiled it into web
assembly we can do the same thing for
python so python there's a
python interpreter written in rust right
you know it's called rust
python you know so you can take that
project you take that project and
compile into web or something towards it
you know using use your favorite user
you know rust compiler to do that and
then you can just run um you know um a
python command shell you know you can
run any pure python applications in
there right
um however you know that's uh um
you know um
there's still a lot of work that needs
to be done because
most python applications out there are
not pure python applications those are
python wrappers around c applications
you know it's uh
it's pretty much you know same approach
that we have just described right you
know we have javascript application
wraps around rust applications right you
know so they cannot simply be
interpreted by russell tyson because
they have native libraries and uh um
however those c libraries could
potentially be compiled into web
somebody as well you know using the same
approach that we have just described
with javascript so this
is pretty much uh you know a
very exciting area that's that's um you
know i think people should be working on
you know of course there's uh um
you know um
because the the networking
uh socket support being what is lacking
so we can't quite do python networking
applications yet we have to incorporate
if we want to run the invoice match we
have to do we have we can incorporate
the watson edge socket api into python
and uh and then support python
frameworks like fast api to turn that
into a micro service framework right you
know so so there are things like that
you know so um you know that's uh that's
still pretty much working progress and
we'd love to uh
collaborate with the community
then there's a another interesting
approach is just to compile
python to c right you know turn the
python code into c code and then turn c
code into webassembly and run inside web
summary runtime so that is another um
you know
interesting approach people have been
trying that but um you know um we can
also see some roadblocks because you
know primarily because um you know not
all c apis are supported in wazi so
you're gonna find something that
things that are missing and um you know
so basically you may your your mind may
vary uh using this approach
and then one of the exciting um you know
happenings last year was um the ruby
team the c ruby team has figured out how
to compile the c based ruby interpreter
into webassembly so they even provide a
very simple tool for that you know so
from their repository you can just uh
you know compile you can compile that
and run that team was made and you would
be able to you know run ruby pure ruby
applications that way
of course you know that's uh um that's
um you know ruby has more language
features than weber somebody can support
for instance that's threat it has
operating system processes and you know
things like that so those things has to
has to be um you know worked out before
this scan can be um it can be a generic
ruby runtime right
so yeah that's uh um
you know
um you know we have got a very quick
overview of you know um of scripting
language support in web assembly using
was managed as an example you know
that's uh um and uh like i said
javascript is probably the most
um is
the one that has most application but
and also the one has the most mature
support and uh um and but python are
getting there you know i think because
there's lots of python developers and a
lot of people are interested in that and
there's a clear roadmap of you know
adding more features to both javascript
and python you know to have them run
better um
in webassembly right you know and uh
ruby is not far behind as well so you
know i think um
hopefully by by this time next year by
the cloud awesome day next year that we
would be able to see um a whole slew of
you know um
scripting language applications running
inside webassembly these are running
inside as serverless functions or as
extensions other platforms you know so
um thank you very much so um i think
that's that's all the time i have um
so um come check out the box match and
um i'll talk to you later thanks